tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono va vj e oggi gioco dei pugni credo
nei ragazzi sarebbe maltratta il tuo
vicino che mancava praticamente solo
questo per concludere in bellezza
non potevo non farlo perché mi piace e
all'ultimo tra l'altro di youtube e vi
così zio vabbè ognuno beve a modo suo
ai pace mio zio che si incazza perché il
gene gli acciaccati in giardino sono
cose che succedono nel fratello mica sei
cascato anche più figo perché anche è
più intima vedevi star calmo zio che ti
fico un manrovescio che ti trovi baffi
al posto dei capelli molto più
interattivo e degli altri ragazzi perché
si può girare con che ragazzi cominciamo
perché sono un fine cosa è quella il
rastrello dai a proviamo con rastrello è
una rotta l'avevo detto io che tifi cavo
manrovescio poi non mi stai ascoltare il
next
vabbè ma non è tanto violento questo
cioè non è che sia stata la stavo
scherzando cani c'è il sesso libero puoi
andare tranquillo ma vabbè sei un boss
fattelo dire se perché a far pagare il
tuo cane di fasto la bottiglia di birra
tanto è caduto su un rastrello non si è
fatto un cazzo
è la madonna che cazzo dagli altri
confronterà non giochi per bambini
poiché però anche anche io voglio
chiamato se mi tocchi ti denuncio la
famiglia tipo così lo vogliono più
giusto e il fratello sono preparate
anche per te guarda qua mascherato
faccia assomiglia un po un booster
brutto stronzo chi dice che violente va
bene e va beh ragazzi il panino secondo
fa vj consiste nel cucinare una faccia e
dal fuoco dei maroni ma non sono neanche
tanto violento ma anche sarai cane c'è
posso alti pensi per la nave perché è la
madonna per casa minchia guarda whisky
appena finito di farla papa va in
giardino a cagare perché tanto c'è
libertà si muove ancora come cazzo
favore se ancora ce niente in confronto
era non ha un cazzo davvero una mail a
una mela come l'ha presa a faccio
katniss everdeen sono pronto per gli
hunger games
esatto è proprio questo che sta ventenne
complimenti per la mira zio hai vinto
tutto questo è questo un tubo colpiti ma
perché clicco il turbo e poi di tali da
una slap atakol ma che senso ha
ok ragazzi questo non si fa ve lo dico
ma è così che nicki minaj se di fatto al
culo tipo non so chiedo ai ragazzi ma se
continua l'altro ecco lo sapessi non ci
avrei scommesso la vita ma allora quanto
sono un miliardo di cose sono 27 cose
diverse non vorrei dire ma ovviamente
sei fermo enzio non ti togliere mai da
lì perché non si sa è che brown vedi che
ha capito tutto
diamogli un premio nobel a sto ragazzo
non è perché veramente un genio sono
ancora ma basta dare cioè una roba che
ancora non ho capito
facciamo di nuovo nicki minaj ok scusami
pensavo capito male gli diamo fuoco per
fare ai ragazzi non ha più o meno è il
livello di caldo che sto sentendo io in
questi giorni regala quindi non è che
cambia molto l'agonia e la stessa un
sasso sei fermo fermo così è fermo al
volo degli prendere
ok lo voglio al volo la libia accusa non
pensavamo capitolo le si prendeva
alveare ok tutto bene frate posso robert
minchia che apre geneticamente
modificate emma bell amado era una per
haga non una bomba a mano
cos'è punto interrogativo bene mimì
mistica vieni vieni via
se lui si è ovviamente certo che sei un
cazzo di genio fatto non ha finito a
scusa eh beh perché se non riempì le
buche soffri solo a metà io vorrei
capire chi cazzo di meta e qual è il
problema mentale di cluster o esatto car
crank cos'è sta cosa è lì da una
bottigliata in testa ma anche cosa
c'entra la bottiglia wrestling scusa mi
ascolta io devo portare la macchina dal
meccanico da mino chiato ok è perfetto
come sentite garden tauro oh mio dio
la paletta la fee chiamo nel culo questa
non non proprio nel culo ma comunque ci
possiamo avvicinare le gare dobbiamo eco
inseriamo perfetto ma di che droghe si
fanno i creatori questi giochi nonché
ragazzi nel cast dai callo che sei
brutto valcar mancano anche su sei più
bello di pinocchio fattori ecco molto
più bello di pinocchio ragazzi non
limitate queste cose perché fa male
perché sei una merda ragazzi la merda mi
manca e usa la bottiglia ovviamente
whisky cosa fai whisky no da whisky
cazzo fischi ma no whisky ma cosa fai
c'è regata più dall swan cup e adesso è
se non la usava adesso mi incazzavo
facciali
e stata 20 volte prima di karina
fatality starò delle cose dello scotch
uno scotch questo li cesoie ragazzi
manca solo questo
non oso pensare che cosa possa ma io
credo che tagli il pelo del cane lo
siamo il cane dio che non è neanche così
male a ok niente a posto grazie ho
capito i pezzi di virus e laddove di
prendi zio sempre meglio e boccia bacio
bacio giorgio shot gun fai un fucile a
canne mozze nella ma che cazzo di senso
a questa roba
ma perché ma perché ma perché guarda che
uscita per una bistecca in un'altra qua
andavano combinato il cazzo mani telo no
vabbè di nuovo stage e nano a laviano
già vista tranquillo e tutto può
costieri mandia dei sventura tranquillo
era anche poi mi avete fatto notare che
c'era anche la key orchi e questa cosa
di rimando ai sventura non ho capito
perché ma una volta che capissi un
rastrello e ti fai male non c'era ma
perché vedo che cadi sempre
glielo concedo ma ho visto di peggio su
etv una catena non seriamente caffè
cinque minuti dopo ma cosa fa la fiom
che cazzo andare 24 ore dopo che mai è
morto non ha la zip
c'è un po fané frate 15 giorni dopo
scheletro ancora pensavo peggio
come cazzo ha fatta a resistere 15
giorni senza mangiare impossibile 45
giorni da eva me che esagerazione una
mosca un anno dopo è vabbè che cazzo è
che bello che se è così che nascono in
via bobby ragazzi poteva essere molto
peggio se pensi che prima tank agata in
bocca c'è una motosega dietro ma no ma
vero fratello 6 leggermente nella
tranquillo voglio solo tagliarla di
scrivere ho scambiato te per l'albero
fratello ma credimi che non era questo
il mio intento del google e le nuvole
cosa succede ai pregato gesù ma come ma
cosa ci sono ragazzi applausi per questa
roba voglio degli app la medaglia che ha
fatto sto gioco medaglia bravo 0
lasciate un mi piace anche voi per gesù
che va bene ma noi lo scotch lo specchio
di bocca e vabbè ma di tele se io
compreso forse lo scotch ma cazzo non ha
fatto male vero 0
la madonna che cazzo era un bazooka
ragazzi è un'esagerazione è una
sparachiodi non un vaso vabbè comunque
la più bella in assoluto per adesso
imbattuta sole nuvole rega è bellissimo
la tasca la laser il cane come strumento
del cane rotta che i maroni che ragazzi
sto cade proprio un [ __ ] lì
ecco proprio non piccoli madonna che
schifo per ragazzi a tutti i massi che
sta guardando sto video a questa cosa
non è venuto tipo un disturbo alle
giuggiola l'iphone e la e la tecnologia
ragazzi che uccide sappiatelo è un
problema questo cinque minuti dopo mi
spaventa ovviamente è rimasto lì ad
aspettare che cazzo è questo il cecchino
è va bene va anche anche tu il bazooka
al posto del cecchino e cioè non si sa
perché quale cosa esplodono al cazzo se
mancano solo più due cose che credo sia
eccola la macchina perfetta che ho fatto
ma anche in tempo a figlia di dirlo
regatanti cazzo cinque minuti dopo mi
fanno paura stessi titoli greci
ragazzi 1 e 2 cm è la stessa sensazione
di quando io faccio stretching mi sento
più o meno così alla fine ma anche
ragazzi uno solo che non ai dati dove
sia cavo elettrico ma che danno lavoro
mica visto questo ma chi colonne sonore
che lo cerco ma seriamente
dopo il carica iphone ragazzi arriva il
carica vicini che una roba che proprio
attacchi alla corretta e si carica
subito epoche una roba istantanea
fantastica era l'ultimo ragazzi crede di
aver finito 27 su 20 set sincero fatta
ed è questo ragazzo in modo giusto per
essere dei vicini perché se mi fanno
incazzare più o meno reagiscono che poi
dovrebbero essere loro incazzati perché
tipo urlo alle 4 di notte per fare i
video ma ok ragazzi questo era in
assunto l'ultimo wac
esistente perché non ne ho più non ce ne
sono più da questa poetica ragazzi che
la serie dei wac è cominciata quando la
ragazza cagava in faccia al ragazzo e
finisce quando il cane cacca addosso al
vicino quindi proprio una roba poetica
meraviglio perché ovviamente la merda
del vicino è sempre più verde cosa sente
ragazzi servizio è piaciuta certamente
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook che
condivida tale iscrizione essendosi
lavori city iscrivetevi altrimenti vi
mando il cane a casa però il cane non è
una bella sorpresa quindi e noi ci
rivediamo nel prossimo video della
ragazza